♫ ♫
Eles dizem que é difícil o Mundial ganhar
Mas com o Ronaldo melhor do mundo
Dá p'ra acreditar
Com o Patricío na baliza nada vai entrar
Com este futebol o mundo vai ter que parar
O telemóvel vou desligar
A nossa seleção vai jogar
Menino te digo tu estás distraído
E vais ter de acordar
E hoje vais ter de saltar
O nosso hino vais cantar
Menino te digo tu estás distraído
E o Quaresma é um safado
De trivela é perigoso
Ele joga gostoso
O Tio Fernando dá a tática
e o Ronaldo faz o golo
Ele joga gostoso
Na defesa temos o Pepe
Ele não é maldoso
Ele joga gostoso
Toca a bola p'ro Moutinho
Ele é habilidoso
Ele joga gostoso
E vai!
Bernadinho e cruza bem devagarinho
Eu disse vai!
Sê teimoso e trata a bola com carinho
Gonçalo!
Cuidado!
Que essas defesas vão fazer de tudo para te parar
O telemóvel vou desligar
A nossa seleção vai jogar
Menino te digo tu estás distraído
E vais ter de acordar
E hoje vais ter de saltar
O nosso hino vais cantar
Menino te digo tu estás distraído
E o Quaresma é um safado
de trivela é perigoso
Ele joga gostoso
O Tio Fernando dá a tática
e o Ronaldo faz o golo
Ele joga gostoso
Na defesa temos o Pepe
Ele não é maldoso
Ele joga gostoso
Toca a bola p'ro Moutinho
Ele é habilidoso
Ele joga gostoso
Eles jogam
Jogam Gostoso
E o Quaresma é um safado
de trivela é perigoso
Ele joga gostoso
O Tio Fernando dá a tática
e o Ronaldo faz o golo
Ele joga gostoso
Na defesa temos o Pepe
Ele não é maldoso
Ele joga gostoso
Toca a bola p'ro Moutinho
Ele é habilidoso
Ele joga gostoso
Somos mais de 12 Milhões em campo com vocês
Vamos mostrar a garra do nosso povo ao mundo
Portugal! Portugal! Portugal!
Só Vai!
Portugal! Portugal! Portugal! Portugal! Portugaaaaaallllll!